[Applause]
[Music]
tomorrow I am releasing a video that I
had already shot and edited in which I
address some things relating to JK
Rowling the video was not exclusively
about her I don't break down everything
that she had said up to that point and
it was shot prior to the release of her
three thousand word essay which was I
supposed meant to justify things she has
been saying but I'm not really going to
delve into that too much either I did a
serious breakdown back in December when
the Maya for stater that happened I
don't have the energy to go over what
she said previously now what she's
released in this essay I am going to
recommend two videos by Jessie gender
both linked in the description that do
an excellent job of breaking down both
of those and explaining the problems
what I need to talk about here because I
don't address it in tomorrow's video
because things hadn't quite escalated to
the to the point they are right now when
I shot it I need to talk about to what
degree Harry Potter is going to have a
place in my life and on this channel
now you may have guessed from the fact
that I am wearing my slithering gear
that I am NOT planning to get rid of all
my stuff
I did consider it last night I actually
came here into the office where I shoot
intent on taking down any visible items
on the shelf relating to Harry Potter
but I found that when I reached for them
I stopped the reason I stopped wasn't
because I'm so in love with Harry Potter
I liked Harry Potter a lot the books the
movies were things that I enjoyed its
the fandom that I loved it's the
community that I love it's my house
that I love and those things are
separate from the author who are the
works they grew out of that but she did
not create the fandom in the way the
fandom works or the way that I have
operated within it and not to mention
all of the things that I mentioned or
that you see their gifts Hedwig figurine
up there this sweater this tie I have
bookends all of these were gifts given
to me by people know me and love me and
accept me and I will not throw away
thoughtful gifts given to me by my
friends and family because of someone
else's hate
that said you are not going to see me in
this outfit
for some time I have no intention to
talk in future about Harry Potter on
this channel I consider taking my old
videos down both the positive and the
critical ones I'm not going to do that
but what I am going to do is I am going
to put a comment on each one of those
videos with a link to this video and pin
it as the top comment on those to give
context of where I am now versus when I
made those videos while I do not intend
to get rid of my Harry Potter stuff I'm
also not going to purchase anything
related to Harry Potter and future even
if it was created and unofficial means
you know things like Etsy which you know
wouldn't be done as official merchandise
and I would also ask as much as I adore
the gifts that I have I would ask that
if anyone wants to send me anything in
future that it not be Harry Potter
themed I've gone through my Amazon
wishlist and removed any Harry Potter
related items from it I don't want my
money going towards this franchise
anymore nor do I want other people's
money going towards it to give me things
when the next fantastic beast movie
comes out I will not pay to see it my
original intent if you'd asked me a week
ago was that I was probably going to go
see it but I was also going to donate
the cost of my ticket to a trans charity
to try and balance the books but that's
not good enough I'm I can't in good
conscience put money towards this
franchise anymore but I'm still going to
keep what I have
I'm going to hold on to my connections
that I have either built or have been
strengthened through a shared love of
this property this property the story
these books these movies that are about
acceptance they are about finding your
place in the world they are about coming
into a world that is more accepting and
right for you than the world that you
lived in for most of your life it's
about all those things and for those
reasons I will hold onto it for now
there may come a time where I may decide
to move on from it but if I do it will
be at my time at my pace and am i
choosing not because I felt forced out
if you feel the need to get rid of your
Harry Potter things if you have them I
understand if you think I am wrong and
you are mad at me that I intend to keep
my Harry Potter related things I also
understand but the simple fact is that I
am a stubborn bastard I am cunning I am
ambitious I am a Slytherin your hate is
not going to move me but I do hope that
you will put thought towards what has
been said and I hope you do not ignore
it I wish now only to remind you that
you are beautiful you are valid and you
are loved you are the counsel I'm only
running the meetings and barring
tomorrow's video which has already been
shot and edited
this will be the last time for the
foreseeable future that this council
will address Harry Potter fantastic
beasts or miss Rowling and for this time
until we meet again this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]